on a cru à chaque fois que notre heure
avait sonné on entendait des cris de
victimes des tirs des gens affolés qui
couraient et leur poursuivant qui
criaiit Allah Akbar Laura a 35 ans elle
a assisté au plus près au massacre de
dizaines de personnes par les
terroristes du Hamas samedi dernier dans
le désert du ngev elle nous raconte sous
le choc comment elle a échapper aux
terroristes vers 6h du matin la musique
du festival s'arrête brusquement avant
que les organisateurs annoncent dans les
haut-parleurs des tirs de roquettes et
ordonnent aux festivaliers de se mettre
à terre elle entend dire que des
personnes sont tombées sous les balles
et que des attaquants tirent sur toutes
les voitures qui quittent les lieux
alors que Laura s'apprête à partir au
volant de sa propre voiture elle se gare
aussitôt je me suis dit qu'il fallait se
rapprocher du point de sécurité de la
manifestation pour se mettre à l'abri
sauf que les tueurs sont sur place et
tire sur les participants j'ai compris
que les terroristes étaient parmi nous
c'est alors que Laura aperçoit une
caravane avec son mari et ses cinq amis
il s'enferme dedans tous se mettent au
sol muets les portables en mode
silencieux vers 10h du matin ils
entendent des pas se rapprocher d'eux et
voient que la poignée de la caravane
verrouillée se baisse un terroriste
tente d'ouvrir puis discrètement Laura
essaie de joindre la police dans la
caravane il fait plus de 45°gr des tir
commence alors à viser la caravane une
balle frôle la tête de son mari puis
silence une heure plus tard d'autres pas
s'approchent et la poignée est encore
baissée il y a des gens là-dedans lâche
un terroriste un marteau à la main avec
mon mari on s'est dit au revoir avec les
yeux avec les yeux encore on s'est dit
que l'on s'aimait je me suis dit que
cette fois on allait mourir j'ai prié
d'ailleurs pour cela car je ne voulais
pas être emmené par les terroristes et
subir les pires sévices après une heure
de combat Laura et ses amis sortent
enfin et découvrent le massacre le sol
était jonché de corps de tout
âge
Laura est arrivée en Israël quand elle
avait 8 ans elle a passé 7 ans dans
l'armée l'armée m'a sauvé tous les
réflexes qu'elle m'a enseigné me sont
revenus je me suis débarrassé de toute
émotion pour agir mais a-t-elle encore
la force de rester en Israël pour
l'instant je reste je dois enterrer tous
mes amis
[Musique]
décédés